hello and welcome to the take with
safety Ridge live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster well Parliament may
be on recess this week but we are not
going anywhere and neither is Boris
Johnson he's back in the news again
after very publicly offering all of his
unredacted WhatsApp messages to the
covert inquiry well now the cabinet
office will decide whether or not to
hand them over what's holding them back
well remember it's not just messages
that Boris Johnson sent but once he
might have received from other members
of the government on the show today
we'll bring you takes from all sides
over the next 60 Minutes including
joining us this evening energy Minister
Amanda soloway from the government and
we'll also be talking to the former
number 10 Chief of Staff Lord barwell
plus we'll talk to Labor's Shadow
employment Minister Justin matters and
much more besides on take
[Applause]
[Music]
hello good evening Boris Johnson is once
again dominating things here at
Westminster but there's been plenty more
going on as well so let's start with the
best bits of the week so far in a
statement that's just been released that
all of Boris Johnson's material
including whatsapps and notebooks that
have been requested by the covert
inquiry has been handed now to the
cabinet office in full and in on through
because it's broken the deadlock really
and the standoff between the baroness
Hallett lady Hallett the retired appeal
court judge and the government in
particular and also Boris Johnson
absolutely certain and confident that
the cabinet office will be engaged in
this in exactly the right kind of way we
start this hour with breaking news ITV
says it has instructed a barrister to
carry out an external review of The
Facts following Phillip schofield's
statement and departure from this
morning so we happen to be in the news
at the moment and of course we
appreciate that it started to had the
ITV brand and this morning brand which
is very wholesome and the facade of that
started crumbling over the past week or
so it started hurting the bottom line as
well ITV shares down one percent the U.S
has moved a step closer to averting a
disastrous default on its debt it's
about money of course it is but it's
also very much about politics the debt
ceiling is the cap on U.S borrowing
without lifting that debt ceiling
America wouldn't be able to pay its
bills after weeks of negotiations we
have come to an agreement in principle
we still have a lot of work to do but I
believe this is an agreement in
principle that's worthy of the American
people
we'll be talking a bit more on the show
about the issues in the US with our U.S
correspondent Mark stain but first a man
who knows a thing or two about Russians
in the conservative party and are
working to the cabinet office and
Downing Street that's the former number
10 Chief of Staff Law barwell who joins
us now live thanks very much for being
with us
um so Bros Johnson's handed over his
unredacted whatsapps do you think the
cabinet office should pass them on to
the covert inquiry now I do yeah I think
that lots of people viewing this program
will have lost loved ones in the
pandemic they have a right to answers
about what the government got right what
it got wrong what the lessons are the
last time the government set up this
inquiry they presumably trust baroness
they put in charge with it and they
should trust her to make the judgment
about what can be put into the public
domain and what can't I think if
they don't hand over this material then
people are not going to have confidence
that the inquiry seeing everything that
it needed to see
I guess just to put the counter argument
do you think there's a nervousness about
people's right to privacy here um you
know we've seen what's happened when
Matt Hancock's whatsapps end up in the
public domain some fascinating but
perhaps not really relevance messages
getting out there could be a bit
embarrassing
yeah so I think there's three things I
say that firstly it depends what you
mean by privacy so if you mean messages
that are unconnected with the pandemic
response then I think the government
needs to trust the inquiry that those
things are not going to find their way
into the public domain if you mean
messages between ministers before the
government have made a collective
decision which I think is what the real
concern is then normally I think those
things should stay private but this is
an exceptional circumstance thousands
and thousands of people lost their lives
and all of us suffered significant
restrictions on our freedoms and I think
that justifies sharing that information
so the inquiry can really get to the
bottom of what happened and you're quite
right to say Sophie that it might be
some of the messages might be
embarrassing for some ministers I guess
probably if you're on my WhatsApp
messages were all shared we might find
one or two of them embarrassing but it's
not really about whether ministers are
embarrassed it's not about finding
individuals who've said embarrassing
things it's trying to understand how the
government decided to do what it did
where the mistakes were made right and
so I'd say to ministers you know you've
got to kind of look it's not about you
it's about getting the truth for all
those people in this country many of
them may be watching this program who
lost people in the pandemic and want to
understand what went on and I think the
government needs to see the bigger
picture there
I guess one of the reasons that I'm
wondering whether or not there's a
certain nervousness in government at the
minute is because these are not messages
that were just sent by Boris Johnson
there could be messages received by him
as well including the person who was
then Chancellor now prime minister is
this perhaps part of the reason there is
this reluctance to hand them over
that may well be a factor you know
there'll be a number of people still
serving in government who are ministers
at that time
but I just come back to the point that I
was trying to make to you that these
inquiries often are difficult for
ministers embarrassing first I I had to
give evidence to the grenful inquiry and
going through the decisions you took and
working out where you got things right
and where you made mistakes it's painful
but it's not about you it you know the
the reason you give that evidence is to
try and help a the families of people
who lost loved ones understand what went
on they have a right to hear the truth
and also because
the purpose of these inquiries isn't
just find someone to blame it's to learn
lessons because there is going to be
another pandemic and we need to make
sure that next time we do a better job
of responding to it and we can only do
that if we get to the truth about what
really went on in government and how
these decisions were made so I'm sure
you're right that there's a nervousness
about what some of these messages are
going to look like
but as I said you've got to see the
bigger picture here and you've got to
trust the the person that the government
has put in charge of this inquiry
just to zoom out for a minute we're once
again talking about Boris Johnson do you
think Rishi sunak is ever going to be
able to escape his shadow
um so I think I think Boris Johnson is
going to lean large over our politics
for a long time to come and a lot of the
issues that Sunnah has had to deal with
are problems that he's inherited from
Boris Johnson whether it's sorting out
the Northern Ireland protocol all the
accusations in relation to Dom Rod
there's a whole range of these issues
that have landed on his desk that are
not of his making but I suspect
fascinating as it is for everybody in
the Westminster bubble that actually
most people in this country are not
interested in the psychodrama within the
conservative party they want to
understand what went on in government
during that critical period so you know
we mustn't allow that psychodrama to
distract us from the core issue here
which is making sure that the inquiry
has the information it needs to do its
job
if I may and I agree with you about the
psycho drama but I'm just going to dwell
on it for one more moment if I may
um do you think this is also partly
about the let's be frank pretty toxic
relationship between Boris Johnson and
Richie sunac is Boris Johnson trying to
be as unhelpful as possible here saying
look I'm going to get them all over I'm
going to get them unredacted it's not my
problem
um I I suspect uh he feels that the
statement he put out tonight has put the
cabin office in a very difficult
position and he probably takes a little
bit of pleasure from that but I mean I'm
as you probably know I'm not uh I'm not
a member of the Boris Johnson fan club
but I actually think he's done the right
thing here
um the inquiry needs to see this
information so him saying well if the
cabin office won't do it if I'm asked
for it I will provide it I think he's
done the right thing even if you're even
if you're not his biggest fan you should
give him some credit for that
fair enough
um I want to say as well thank you for
taking the time out this evening we've
seen a couple of your family members I
think drifting around in the background
which I think just shows you know that
you're juggling probably a million
things and we'll let you get back to
family life thank you very much
hey Gavin barwell at speaking to us
there well let's get the view from the
government now a little earlier I spoke
to the energy and consumer Minister
Amanda soloway she's in charge when you
push to get people to claim all of the
energy support that's available I did
though of course have to start with that
news about Boris Johnson
we're just going to start on Boris
Johnson and it does feel like he's
always in the news at the minute and but
the covid-19 inquiry demanded his
unredacted whatsapps from the pandemic
he's now handed them to the cabinet
office are they going to give them to
the inquiry
um I I don't know I mean obviously the
inquiry has been
um started to make sure that we actually
look at the pandemic
um examine it rigorously think about
Lessons Learned think about the
transparency uh ensure that obviously
um we do do the right thing in the
future
um so far as you all know there's been a
lot of information that has been handed
over I know that
um the Prime Minister has committed to
being
um helpful
um so I can't preempt what's going to
happen but like you I've just seen the
news so that that's as far as I I have
on this understood
um I guess some would wonder why the
cabinet office wouldn't hand over the
unredacted messages I mean if you were
being cynical I guess you might wonder
if it's because Rishi sunak other
members of the government might have
some incriminating messages themselves
between them and Boris Johnson
as I say I I can't preempt what what is
going to happen next
um I just I do believe that the right
thing to do has been is the inquiry
because we definitely need to look at
Lessons Learned and completely unique
time that we went through but in terms
of um preempting what's going to happen
I'm I'm afraid I can't do that I mean I
get that you know you obviously think
the inquiry is a good thing and for the
reason you've outlined they've asked for
the unredacted messages so why would you
not give them to them
my understanding is that everybody that
the prime minister is committed to
helping in this situation is committed
to the inquiry
um the cabinet officer as well and um
you know the inquiry is ongoing so I
don't want to be preempting what uh what
will be happening
okay understood
um now you've come on the show you've
talked about Boris Johnson and so let's
talk a bit about what you want to talk
about and it is important and because
you're trying to make sure that people
claim the energy support that's
available to them so what's the plan
there
yeah so as you will know over winter for
a six-month period
um everybody had uh who was available
was had 67 pounds or thereabouts popped
into their account to help towards
energy bills in the case of prepayment
meters the way that this was delivered
was through a voucher system that was
usually posted by the supplier on
occasion very rarely was was emailed and
so far we've had around about 650
million pounds of support has been given
to people on prepayment meters however
um the time the Redemption time will be
is June the 30th and so today we're
having a day where we're going around
and saying please let's sit do all that
we can we've done so much already we've
had leaflets we've engaged with uh post
office been out to cabs I've been
holding stakeholder meetings lots and
lots of different things that we have
been doing but we're having one final
effort to make sure that people are
reducing the vouchers and it's really
important for me to do this because it
could be obviously there could be vacant
properties people could have moved but I
also am concerned that it's a group of
vulnerable people who haven't realized
that they have had these vouchers
through the post or in in their email
and so that that's why we're having a a
final push on this
uh really important as you say for all
those people to make sure that they do
have access to the money that they have
available to them
um there's one other story that I'm Keen
to talk to you about that's emerged
recently um and that's about speeding
fines or driving fines and you repaid an
80 pound fine that you claimed on
expenses in 2020. yes what was that for
yeah
um so
um first of all
um when I had the news I was just
absolutely devastated I had
um you know um I wouldn't
um intentionally want to do um anything
it was a a it was a genuine admin error
and it was for a congestion charge and
um obviously as soon as I found out I
paid it back and I'm also making sure
that I look at ways in the future making
sure that this doesn't happen again
um but the fact is it did happen I paid
it back and
um you know
um that that's one of the I knew I would
be likely to be asked about this today
however I wanted to come on want to to
say you know it's a genuine mistake and
I have paid it back but two I also want
to make sure that we go back to really
important point that a group of people
for the 400 pounds is such an important
amount of money and if we don't uh what
I really want I'm concerned about is it
could be a group of people who aren't
opening their letters who aren't
answering the door who actually we
should be doing something about and so
my play is if you haven't redeemed your
voucher do so but if you know anybody
who might be on a prepayment meter who
could have received one of these
vouchers knock on the door or encourage
them to redeem these vouchers
a query on the fine
St accidentally claim for a congestion
fine on your expenses
I think well it was it was done in
narrow I did I didn't do it it was it
was done in in error but as soon as I've
discovered it I've paid it back
okay and just to end I've got to ask
about that Blondie picture behind you
it's oh yeah there you go are you a
super fan
yeah um I I I love artwork and it was it
was just I like black and white as you
can probably tell
um yes so there we go okay thank you
very much indeed thank you thank you you
take care bye-bye
all right on the program today we have
got lots of analysis from our chief
political correspondent John Craig who's
with me now one big story in Westminster
today all about these Boris Johnson
unredacted WhatsApp messages what do you
think the government's line is right now
is it going to hold well up to now it
has been that we don't want to hand over
all these uh all these uh documents and
all these uh WhatsApp messages notebooks
and so on uh they say they said in a
pretty Punchy statement our view is that
the inquiry doesn't have the power to
record Quest what they keep calling
unambiguously irrelevant information
that's beyond the scope of this
investigation they're talking about
people who are a government employees
having the right to a private life these
emails are perhaps not about work
they're personal and so on now I thought
was interesting in your interview with
Gavin barwell
um he said that this inquiry is an
exception he said normally I'd agree you
don't have to hand over all this
material real that this is an exception
he said we owe it to the people who lost
their relatives of those who lost their
lives and uh so that argument perhaps
will sway in Whitehall hasn't yet and uh
really and we all know that Boris
Johnson likes a game of tennis well he's
put the ball firmly in Richie sunax
court tonight hasn't he yeah he has this
is the interesting thing isn't it
because in a way you think this is all
about Boris Johnson who's saying he'll
hand over his messages but is it really
about what she seen that do you think
and well he was Chancellor and of course
he had this policy of eat out to help
out which some claim uh caused some
damage caused some people to perhaps
catch covid
um obviously it costs a lot of money
um what what went on what what clashes
between ministers I mean there were
suggestions weren't there that perhaps
Chris witty the chief medical officer
perhaps was not keen on that all sorts
of disagreements May emerge of course
and that's there is a suspicion amongst
some MPS this is all about protecting
not just the Prime Minister but other
ministers who are still in government
one thinks of Michael go for example are
the key players I mean I thinking back
to all those news conferences in Downing
Street regular attendees were Matt
Hancock's not in government anymore but
Grant shafts was that some of those
wasn't he and so I think there will be
nervousness I mean the liberal Democrats
have been saying the last 24 hours you
can't keep using Boris Johnson as an
excuse and there is a suspicion perhaps
they are so uh the clock's ticking four
o'clock tomorrow they've got to make up
their mind if they go to court that'll
look terrible won't it trying to go
withhold some of the information bad
politics if they do that it really is um
at the same time they you do wonder how
bad some of these whatsapps could look I
mean do you think this kind of gets to
the core issue about what's that because
people do use it in quite casual way you
make jokes on it you know I'm thinking
there you mentioned Michael gay for some
of those messages that were linked to
between him and Matt Hancock for example
it's a bit blurred government by
WhatsApp these days isn't it do you
remember when Tony Blair became prime
minister people criticizing for what was
called sofa government because he had
all these informal meetings without
civil servants but we now have very much
have and we saw it actually in the leak
of the Matt Hancock whatsapps that he
handed to Isabel oakshop the journalist
and they appeared all over the Daily
Telegraph so we now embarrassing these
can be and our own colleague Sam coats
has come up with some belter whatsapps
hasn't he between conservative back
benches uh people are pretty Indiscreet
at times aren't they and we know from
Dominic Cummings for example some of the
insults that were flying around some of
the things he was saying for example
about Matt Hancock and he called Boris
Johnson the trolley didn't he a
supermarket trolley out of control so
there could be real box office great for
us but embarrassing for the government I
think that's it it feels very intimate
doesn't it but there is still a record
of what you write on WhatsApp uh John
thanks very much answers we'll have more
from John later on in the program you
are watching the take we're live in
Westminster for you this evening next up
we're going to be going live to
Washington night for an update on the
negotiations over the debt ceiling and
the latest on the battle to be the
Republican Presidential nominee
[Music]
welcome back live to Westman so you're
watching the take well we are live in
Westminster we want to go to the
Washington now because the United States
government is considered so reliable as
a borrower that the certainty that it
will repay its debts forms the basis for
much of global finance and so default
seemed Unthinkable but it all got a bit
thinkable in the last few days and weeks
because the Democratic White House and
the Republican Congress couldn't agree a
deal to raise the debt ceiling which
limits how much the U.S can borrow well
let's get the latest live from
Washington DC now with our U.S
correspondent Mark Stone Mark how
serious are things there
uh hi Sophie I I think it is only in
America that you could have quite such a
high stakes game of chicken but that is
what has been happening uh here over the
course of the past few weeks it hasn't
got massive headlines beyond the United
States I think largely because the the
the
um the expert consensus has been that
even even the crazies over on Capitol
Hill would eventually come to their
senses and the game of chicken would end
uh peacefully the the pro the issue
though is that if it doesn't and there
is still a question mark
um then the impact for all of us of the
United States defaulting uh is
absolutely huge this isn't about the
United States government shutting down
you may remember we've we've heard that
in the past the government shuts down
because they can't get a deal on
whatever this is different this is about
defaulting or on its debt but and not
being able to pay uh its bills because
they can't agree to raise the debt
ceiling well it's coming to a head
tonight on Capitol Hill those two men
you just saw there the president and
Kevin McCarthy the the Speaker of the
House have been hammering it out for
days now these are two men who have
fundamentally different Visions for
America one
um the the the center left president
some say pretty far left president the
other a right-wing Republican and they
are trying uh to get the people that you
can see there to vote tonight at Harper
State local time uh to agree a deal that
they have hammered out but there are
people on the the far right of politics
um the troublemakers to the right of
Kevin McCarthy uh who do not want this
deal to go through and then there are
those on the far left of politics uh the
likes of Bernie Sanders who also don't
want this deal to go through
um now I think they've probably find
themselves with with certain amount of
cover now in that they it will go
through and they can vote against on
principle the reality though is that
this fails and they go back to the
negotiating table and ultimately if it
fails completely well then yes the
global economy is in big trouble but it
does does appear as though they do have
a deal a cap on spending for the next
two years conservative measures which
would claw back money allocated to
several departments and the Liberals
would retain student loan debt relief
it's kind of in the weed stuff as far as
we're concerned on the other side of the
Atlantic uh yes
um but it's massively important that the
moment to watch for is half past eight
local time tonight that's where it will
they hope go through uh the House of
Representatives that you're looking at
there then it goes over to the Senate um
if it passes there well then the game of
chicken is over but it's been high stake
stuff no question about that some might
say manufactured Jeopardy in order that
both sides get what they want but it's
still Jeopardy
high stakes game of chicken I think that
is the perfect way of summing it up and
Mark I want to make the most of having
you on the program tonight and ask you a
bit about the U.S election as well if I
may because I feel like there's often an
assumption that look it's going to be
Biden versus Trump but that's not
necessarily the case is it the
Republican race has been hot enough a
bit recently
yeah the elections is until November
next year but as always the election
season here gets underway very very
early the Democratic Party candidate is
is Joe Biden uh that much it is clear
he's the uh he's the incumbent president
he said he's going to run again uh no
one will really stand in his way but on
the other side on the right uh yes uh
Donald Trump is the presumptive
candidate based on the polls he is way
ahead of all the others he's announced
he's going to run but behind him uh is
uh Ron DeSantis the governor of Florida
doing pretty well
um a man who does not one bits the eye
to eye with Donald Trump anymore they
are very much at loggerheads they're
throwing uh insults at each other uh
Donald Trump has been has been uh
calling him Rhonda sanctimonious for
quite some time
um but and um Rhonda Santos has more
recently been been upping his punches
towards Donald Trump as well so those
are the two candidates which I guess the
headlines are focusing on and they are
angry candidates they they thrive on
division they thrive on on presenting
the country as falling apart and that
they are the only the only people who
can bring it back together in a very
conservative way behind them though
Sophie I think there are some some
really interesting people that yes only
have a crumb of support at the moment
but we're a long way from the election
things could change the two that I think
are worth watching
um just because they're they're their
Persona is different from those those
main two uh Tim Scott and Asia Hudson
Hutchinson Tim Scott is a senator out
from South Carolina he is the only black
Republican uh in the Senate
um he is very conservative his views on
abortion his views on guns are as you
would expect them to be
um but his style is so different he is
not all about anger and division he is
not an angry candidate in the way that
Donald Trump and uh Rhonda Santos are
presenting uh themselves um Asia
Hutchinson is a a former governor of
Arkansas also a man with just a crumb of
support at the moment but a man who
hopes to do a lot better again the
Persona of his is one um of
inclusiveness trying from his very
conservative point of view to bring the
country together in a way that many
would argue Trump and DeSantis are not
now the problem that these two men have
got with their inclusive
um Vibe is that many of the people on
the right of politics are angry as As
Trump and DeSantis are they are angry
because they feel they have been
neglected they are angry because they
feel that they're conservative values
are being eroded and so that anger
perhaps is what's actually going to
drive uh the politician drive people to
the uh to the to vote rather than the
inclusive more wholesome candidacies of
Hutchinson and Scott
it's really interesting I mean you were
mentioning there about Donald Trump as
well saying that he's the candidate to
be if you look at the polling and
there's a story that's come out today
isn't there saying that he's been
captured on tape talking about a
classified document that he kept after
leaving
the White House that's CNN reporting
apparently an audio recording I think of
a 2021 meeting in which Trump
acknowledges he held on to a classified
Pentagon document is this the kind of
thing that could impact Donald Trump or
is it again is he a bit of a Teflon
candidate you know is this more of a
Ducks back
he has he has a base of support which
from our our Journeys around the country
uh is holding there's no question about
that but but his uh his base has a
ceiling um and uh the the continued uh
sort of issues that he has got legal
issues he's got and this one is the
latest just emerging now on on CNN that
um uh of all remember some classified
documents um were found at his
Mar-A-Lago a point uh apart his
Mar-A-Lago residence he he said that
yeah they were there but he Declassified
them because he has the right to do that
there's a question mark over whether he
does have the right but now it emerges
that Federal prosecutors say that they
have a recording of him saying that he
took a classified document uh back in
2021 uh related to a potential attack on
Iran uh the inference there that he knew
it was classified and yet he took it
anyway this is one of so many issues uh
that is
um that is causing Trump trouble and I
think there will be a proportion of
Voters who are fed up with the chaos
that surrounds Donald Trump and they'll
look for something different the
question is will they look for uh
DeSantis who is seen as Trump without
the chaos same policies same trumpian
Vibe but without the chaos or they look
for someone are perhaps a little bit
more inclusive um at the moment the
polls suggest it would be Trump or de
Santa's it's gonna be a fascinating race
it really is Mark thank you very much
Mark's down there with the latest from
Washington you're watching the take we
are live in Westminster for you up next
we're going to be hearing from labor and
also taking a closer look at just how
much the two-party leaders major Party
leaders are viewed across the country
[Music]
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching the take well time now
to get the view from labor a little
earlier I spoke to the party's Shadow
employment Minister Justin matters
so Boris Johnson has said that he has
handed over his unredacted whatsapps to
the cabinet office should they now
release them to the covid-19 inquiry
yes the children I think it's probably
important to say that Boris Johnson's
handed them in late already I don't know
what the problem was
um but it's a bit of a mess when you
have the government uh instigating an
inquiry in fact it was Boris Johnson who
sat this up uh presumably on the basis
that they will cooperate with it and
then we've had all this this argument
about what should and shouldn't be
disclosed and I think it's really
important that they get full disclosure
because it's important for public
confidence that the inquiries seem to be
robust that the families of loved ones
have all their questions answered and
importantly as well we learn lessons
about what's gone wrong and the only way
that can happen for sure is if all the
information is funded over to the judge
leading inquiry then she can make the
decisions about what is relevant and
what isn't
I guess just to put the counter argument
in you know we've seen how easy it is
for whatsapps to end up in the public
domain with the Matt Hancock WhatsApp so
I'm sure everyone enjoyed seeing you
know Michael Gove Matt Hancock sending
love heart emojis to each other but is
it really relevant and in the public
interest is it fair enough that people
should expect a degree of privacy
well I think it's important that these
messages are disclosed because it's very
clear from the exchanges in fact between
Matt Hancock and Michael goat the policy
was being made in that way indeed they
made a joke about meetings being a
therapeutic environment where people
could express their concerns before you
and I decide the policy that was what
Michael Gove said to Matt Hancock so
it's clear actually that these messaging
apps have been used to formulate
government policy which is why it's so
important that the inquiry gets to see
them all
okay
um I just want to talk about your brief
for a minute because you're the shadow
Minister for employment rights and I was
thinking before the interview it strikes
me that we're going through a bit of a
watershed moment when it comes to what
behavior is isn't acceptable in the
workplace you know we've obviously seen
it with the CBI Tesco Phillip Schofield
and ITV I don't know if you think that
there is something happening a bit of a
watershed
well I think I think it's important that
anyone whose behavior is unacceptable in
the workplace is challenged and actually
people are confident enough to actually
challenge that behavior now clearly some
of these issues have been going on for
many years and haven't been uh capable
of being challenged but it's important
to Once someone steps forward and makes
those kind of uh complaints that they're
taken seriously that steps taken to
actually address them and organizations
have seen to have a good look at
themselves as well to see whether
they've actually handled things properly
in the past
and not to talk about anything specific
because I know that people query some
allegations and feel that they've been
wrongfully treated in individual cases
but do you think that it's a good thing
that culture does seem to be shifting
more widely
absolutely and obviously we know in
Parliament there's been been plenty of
allegations about inappropriate conduct
bullying and harassment and we
absolutely need to make sure that
everyone feels comfortable and treated
with respect and dignity when they go
into work and anything we can do to to
help that has got to be uh welcomed
and there's just one other story I'd
like to ask you about and labor has
taken 1.4 million pounds in donations
from the founder of just stop oil are
you comfortable with that
well I think it's probably another way
of putting it is that we've taken
donations from uh Dale Vince who is the
owner of ecotricity which is a
multi-million pound company you could
you could talk about it in that sense
you could also talk about it in the
sense that the conservatives have taken
donations off individuals who have
funded organizations that deny climate
change we're not responsible for what an
individual uh chooses to to support in
other areas but what we're very clear is
that the tactics have just stopped oil
are not acceptable
at the same time though you know we will
talk to the conservatives about these
allegations as well and about donations
that they get but I guess you know 1.4
million pounds what do you think they're
hoping for in relation to that donation
people don't normally give 1.4 million
pounds out the goodness of their hearts
well I think I think if you if you talk
to uh Dale Vince about what he's seen
from the labor party particularly in
recent years it's a real commitment to
tackling climate change you will know
about our green investment plan to
really green the economy and that's sort
of that we feel very passionately about
he's obviously wanting us to to carry on
with that and get a chance to deliver
that in government it's certainly not a
case that uh you know he who pays the
pipe for calls the tune
what's your view more widely on just a
point do you think it's one of those
cases where you know the ends justifies
the means
well look I I think the fact that that a
lot of the discussion about just stop
oil ends up being about the tactics that
they use and the disruption that they
cause and obviously when people are
stopped from getting to work or
ambulances are unable to go and treat
patients or get to hospital it becomes a
completely different debate and and I
think you know I would ask them to
reflect really on whether the disruption
they're causing is actually doing their
their cause more harm than good
okay thank you very much indeed for
being on the program but always good to
talk thank you
well we've heard from the government and
labor time now to sort of zoom out and
look at some of the wider issues in
politics because there have been
Arguments for years about whether the UK
political system is getting more
presidential with a focus on the leader
rather than the party so what about the
two main Party leaders now just how much
of an asset are they with crucial parts
of the electorate ahead of the general
election next year Well presumably next
year we're joined Now by Luke Trill who
is the UK director of more in common uh
former uh government's bad as well uh he
has some constant quite interesting
polling on that haven't you so what
what's the main takeaway then well what
we wanted to look at was how much of an
asset was each of the leaders to their
respective uh political parties it's
been the suggestion that although the
conservatives are in the polling
doldrums that actually Rishi sunak's
personal appeal might be enough to pull
them over the line and what came back
was really interesting so first of all
voters agreed that Rishi sanak was an
asset to the party they definitely
thought actually he was better than the
conservative brand but the interesting
thing was when we asked the same
question about Kia stama voters were
almost as likely to say that KIA stama
was an asset to his party too in fact
actually what we tend to find in our
focus groups is people tend to think the
same things about both leaders actually
they think they're both kind of
competent they're both kind of good at
the job but they worry that both of them
are perhaps a little bit Posh and out of
touch with their lives I've got to ask
the question we're looking at some of
that polling you can see the overall
very similar between case Dharma
but
to this as well right so you know you
might say oh quite like Pep Guardiola
but if you really hate Man City you're
still going to want them to lose right
absolutely that you know what is driving
politics at the moment is perceptions of
the two parties
um and voters haven't suddenly given the
Tories a free pass you know they
remember what happened with Boris what
happened with the mini budget and that's
driving the opinion polls at the moment
but I guess the Tories had this hope
that perhaps if sunak was far more
popular than Kia stamina it might be
enough to carry them over the line when
people really focus on who do we want as
prime minister what that polling show is
certainly at the top level there really
isn't that much difference between the
two of them that's really interesting
you've also broken it down into key
voter groups I just want to have a quick
look at some of this I think we can show
you one on the screen uh now so this is
loyal nationalists actively people in oh
sorry nationalism I should get that one
right
effectively red wall voters what's this
showing yeah so this is the group of
Voters who swung behind Boris Johnson
and delivered victory in the red wall
you know they're traditionally labor
voters but switched to the conservatives
after brexit and the really interesting
thing here is that this group of Voters
when you ask them if you snacks an asset
to the conservatives they say no
narrowly but they say no but when you
ask them about Kia starma and whether
he's an asset to the labor party they
say the opposite so it's interesting
amongst that group who will determine
those red wall seats actually more of
them think here storm as an asset to
labor than think Rishi sunax an asset to
the concert and if they do defer to find
the election as many argued at last time
if they Define the election and again
this resonates with what we hear in our
focus groups that Rishi sinach they
really just wonder does he really care
about things like leveling up a lot of
the stories you know things about the
swimming pool the shoes actually cut
through with that group and hard for him
to be able to present that he really
cares and understands their lives so
that's a rebel and we've been hearing
more and more about the blue wall right
say the kind of traditional conservative
seats that are now swinging away from
them sometimes the lib Dems as well this
is what your polling showed when it
comes to who you're describing
established liberals blue wall there's a
quite a difference there between the two
men though absolutely and this is what's
so fascinating so this is your group you
might think of them as being like camera
night Tories in the blue walls more
traditional Tory seats in the south east
and if you ask them about the two
leaders they agree that both leaders are
an asset to their party but Rishi sunak
they think it by a really you know it's
actually quite a stonking margin and
what we've seen with that group of
Voters who didn't particularly like
Boris they didn't you know they actually
tended to vote remain they don't really
like the coach Wars they really like
Rishi sonak and he started to win them
uh back in large numbers and I think
that might be the conservatives hope
with this presidential campaign it might
not be enough to save the party and win
the election it doesn't look like it'll
be enough to help in places like the red
wall but enough of those more
traditional conservative voters might
stick with them to stop it being a 1997
style route it's interesting listening
to you though because you've talked
about those voters and you're saying
they voted to remain they don't like the
culture wars and I'm looking at the
program of government at the minute
that's a lot about stopping the boats
it's a lot about making brexit work and
not going back on on brexit
why are they not trying to appeal to
these blue wall voters that they're
focusing on the red wall voters who if
what you're saying is right they might
have already gone well this is one of
the most fascinating paradoxes that the
group of Voters who most like Rishi
sunak if you actually look at his
ideological profile you know some people
have suggested he's the most socially
conservative prime minister we've had
you know at least since uh the 90s it
doesn't align with them at all and we
think there's a danger that by pursuing
this kind of more culture worry socially
conservative strategy that he doesn't
win back those red wall voters who are
particularly concerned about the cost of
living and the NHS but also these blue
wall voters think oh God he's not quite
what we thought
um actually you know he's more
right-wing than Boris on stuff and he
loses them as well so there's a real
danger that the conservatives find
themselves falling between two stools if
they're not careful
what's your prediction then there's lots
of chat about whether or not Labor's on
course to win a majority they are more
likely to be heading to Coalition
territory if there is a landing zone for
the conservatives where do you where are
you where are you at look I mean what I
always go back to is you know this time
three years ago the conservatives were
on 55 on in the polls they're now about
sort of 28 so this is a very volatile
electorate but I think the thing which
does it for me is we did um we asked uh
people we polled recently to do describe
what they thought of Britain it was for
the New Britain project and the top word
that came up was broken and until that
changes it's really hard to see a path
to a conservative Victory
um at the moment if you were trying for
an election tomorrow I'd be predicting
quite a comfortable labor majority but
there's a year to go we've seen Lots
change already more could still change
it's really interesting thanks very much
for coming on and talking as you through
some of your research thinking
you're watching the take we're live in
Westminster we've had a busy show
already but up next possibly as we were
saying a year to go until the general
election we're going to be looking at
some electoral Cycles from Years Gone by
to see how things compare now
[Music]
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you are watching the take now a general
election is not that far away the smart
money reckons spring or probably Autumn
of next year and it's pretty clear that
the political fight between the major
parties is already hotting up now
Labor's well ahead in the polls expected
to be the largest party but number 10
hopes it's steady the conservative ship
and can pull things around so
are you about a year out from an
election how do things compare to
previous electoral Cycles there is no
one better to ask than our chief
political correspondent John Craig who
joins us again now John what's the first
election that you covered 1983 as a
political journalist yeah there you go
um so John Cena all right John knows
Margaret thatch who had a majority of
144 in that and there you go
um I'm really interested to know your
take on where the next election fits is
it what's it going to be similar to you
talk to MPS the big debate at the moment
is with this big labor opinion poll lead
is it going to be like 1997 when labor
won a massive majority or is it going to
be like 1992 when labor thought they
were going to win and of course John
Major Pips uh them on the April the 9th
anniversary of the day met Norma major
at a Tory event he won by with a
majority of 21. this is Tony Blair in
1997. remember that morning a Festival
Hall a new dawn has broken has it not
I'm not sure if that's photo is at a
festival hall or in Downey so I think
that's the Festival Hall with all those
flags wonderful faces I was actually in
Downing Street that Friday morning when
he walked up Downing Street with Cherie
and uh it was I was quite like put a
good show of the labor party in those
days so the hope I guess for labor is
it's gonna be like 97. they need a swing
like 97. that looks different isn't it
yeah now what happened between 92 and 97
I mentioned that major had a majority of
21. throughout that Parliament uh the
conservatives lost by-election after
by-election after by-election and some
of their Tories MPS defected as well so
when we got to 97 there was no um the
Tories had no majority this time Tori
started off well they started with an
80-seat majority they've got a mountain
to climb as kirst armor keeps
acknowledging good news for them
Scotland's looking better for them
there's a poll recently suggested they
could pick up another 23 seats in
Scotland no wonder Kia stormers on the
shuttle to Glasgow or Edinburgh every
five minutes
um because that's a key background now
this is a poll this is this is the this
shows 1992 I know you like a graph
Sophie I do like a graph yeah a really
interesting one as well look at this
look at let me if I can go over here
look at that massive Gap there that's
when labor had a a 20 plus Point Gap
around about the time when Margaret
Thatcher was very very unpopular and of
course they dumped her in November 1990
but look what happened after that under
John major and the key bit is this bit
here
um I was I mean you say I was I was
political editor for the Daily Express
during the major years and um look at
those polls and look at the very very
last bit the uh the Tories up labor down
after months and months of Labor leads
we in the Daily Express we had the last
opinion poll on the Wednesday morning
and there were virtually neck and neck
and of course Mr major one with a
majority of 21.
um what went wrong for labor some people
blame a shadow budget by Johnson the
late John Smith then there was that
Dreadful Kinect rally triumphalism where
all right he said it's three times I
won't do it three times
um people blame clinic for it and of
course John Smith died in 94. Tony Blair
became leader in the labor recover
really took off people say what would
have happened if John Smith had not died
I think labor would have won in 97 but
not with the landslides that Tony Blair
got fascinating and I guess the takeaway
is you never know what's happening with
politics and that is really what the big
lesson has been for us over the last
Margaret Thatcher always said in
politics the unexpected always happens
there you go analysis there from John
Craig great to have you on the show I
know that John's got to get out of here
to get to your live in the 10 o'clock
news that is it for the take we actually
won't be back next Wednesday but our
Sunday program is back as usual at 8 30
this Sunday next up it is Sky News at
10. thanks very much for watching
another busy week in politics even
though it's recess
School news never stops
foreign
[Music]